[Musik]
das war kanzler ich denke einfach hinter
mir macht noch mal
wir sind heute in mannheim
herzlich willkommen wie gefällt's dir
hier ich wünsche sehr gut auch ja nicht
so weit aus seiner komfortzone
herausholen
wird zwischen ich habe ihn bei uns
aufgenommen er kam einfach mit seinem
truck stand vor der haustüre nicht wahr
so ach komm lass den sympathischen kerl
doch rein genau und dann will ich auch
noch mitbekommen bei mir war schon drin
ja und dann haben uns gedacht stellen
wir uns doch halt nach mannheim direkt
vors q6 q7
war taktisch ganz klug weil wenn uns was
fehlt können wir einfach im shop kurz
bei uns was holen und uns für er nicht
haben ich habe sturm ist ausstattung im
bus schon gesehen da muss einfach mehr
zu halten so ein bisschen was hast du
schon aber wir machen ein bisschen
gemütlicher naja das heißt wer während
die jungs und mädels da hinten noch die
stage vorbereiten gehen wir kurz nach
oben und machen wir so shopping queen so
du hast so viel geld
[Musik]
wir uns beim kochen und backen dann
können wir den noch dazuschreiben
anstimmt oder wir machen wie hieß das
von früher wo man einkaufen kann selber
glaubt ja wir machen super toll klappt
machen wir auf die plätze fertig los
jetzt ausgang hierbei
[Musik]
mehr als zehn minuten zeit einkaufskorb
24 einkaufskörbe und wir packen alle
kleinen wohnwagen brauchen buckel los
geht's
[Applaus]
[Musik]
richten wir hier die küche mal schön ein
geschäften und etikettieren alles jetzt
und dann geht's los würde ich sagen ich
glaube mittagszeit ist bald wir müssen
uns beeilen ok dann räumte schmidt ein
dann wird gekocht und da jetzt gebraucht
ich dachte mir wir packen wir so das
ganze werkzeug so schneide sachen und so
in ein chaos da kannst du dir noch immer
erstaunt wenn du unterwegs bist ein auto
fest kann das ja nicht dekoriert lassen
schön dass man immer alles wegräumen und
dann packen wir da oben
schon sicher für die autofahrer
und das wird dann schon
und ich bin die erste kurve und
dann etikettieren und level wir heute
abend noch mal
[Musik]
was gibt's ja heute
es gibt habe ich alles selber mir
ausgedacht dem champignon gespannt wann
die platte also mit kleinen stamm
beschlüsse zum weihnachtsmarkt
weihnachtsmarkt feeling dann gibt es
noch dazu das weiß ich nicht kenne was
uhr vorbereitet ist das genau der
langusten und das kannst du nicht kennst
du auch erkennen langsam dass wir das
ganze ist glauben dass heute die an das
hört sich an wie lange wird ja
und was gibts mal und da wir auf seinem
kanal es gibt natürlich noch cupcake
jetzt es wurde aus muffin wurden
cupcakes und ich habe gelernt aus und
erfüllen würden kaputt wenn man besser
drauf steht ihr zu machen wir das und
was gibt es heute nicht definitiv nicht
auf
keinen fall noch nie gab es das hier ist
wird es nie geben
weil das ist die ganze laufkundschaft
hier denkt wir machen machen aber wir
essen keine brüder und schwestern ist
ganz einfach wir sind wochentagen
[Musik]
ich habe stimmen heute gibt es keine
waffe das wichtigste heute alle
spaß und entertainment nicht
[Musik]
oh
mein gott das ist so in your face weiß
wie ich jetzt schreibe das wird so ein
drama
ich denke heute noch fast fertig ist
bereits das wird richtig schlimm ja
wirklich schlimm ja ich kann nicht
schreiben ich habe keine schöne
handschrift
[Gelächter]
drama
so seht ihr das nach drama
das ist
hochgehen okay ich bin voll bereit
ok jetzt tun
also dann zeigen wir mal dem jungen was
langosch sind langusten sollten wussten
lange
also langosch ist ein ungarisches gepäck
hefegebäck was frittiert werden das
kenne ich von dir du frierst du auch
sachen und machst oft sachen immer mit
hilfe wenn ich dort bin ja weil ich mag
es wenn dinge so aufgehen deswegen sind
wir froh
und außerdem macht der spitze
und weil ich denn yoshimura glücklich
machen will mit essen gibt's jetzt
frittierte langosch davon ganz gutes
berufsprofil kriegst du gehörst
erhalten zuschuss damit er dann ins
fitnessstudio paradies ist alles weg
gleich zum film is
ja langosch aber die gibt's auf den
türkischen drei sind die fische ich
glaube da gibt es einfach in jeder
sprache weil jeder markt
gewohnt in deutschland ist es wie immer
eine maultasche
also hat jedes dritte gibt's auch schon
auf einem kanal aber schon ziemlich alt
wir brauchen kilo mehl bisschen zucker
ich nehme nur zwei esslöffel mehl hefe
200 gramm ihr
neues löwen sagt vielleicht damit du
nicht alles rein schritte 500 milliliter
wasser und salz das fett kommt kein
freund der das wird ja ins patentierten
das essen
dann machen wir am besten noch anfangen
bisschen schnee wesentliche weil wir
sind jetzt hier im chart wohnung habe
ich auch keine küchenmaschine hütten wir
haben zwar kommen ist momentan mit den
händen profi schneeberge bei dem shop
esslöffel als auch bei allem zu sagen
das gibt es in dem shop da werde ich
immer so gut
wie schlimm das gesagt was ich habe
gutes make-up das gibt mir ich habe
grafiker die grafikabteilung dass wir
daraus machen jetzt einmal komplett
dann haben jetzt die hefe drin zwar ist
noch viel zucker weil der zucker macht
mit der hilfe irgendwas gemacht sollte
sich die legen sich auch salz und hefe
lieben sich nicht gar nicht nur am ende
dann sogar wie immer gleich dazu und
salz immer erst noch endet auf die
hilfen über so ein bisschen wie urlaub
die hilfe hier macht liebe und das gute
wiesentaler wasser vom camel danke kevin
ist von unserem arzt von uns von euch
und von wiesenthal mineralbrunnens der
läuft einmal unter dem friedhof durch
aber daher schmeckt ganz ganz ganz gut
das war schon immer so erkennen sie
gespräche mit computer
das habe ich ja mal tatsächlich mit
kennt ihn
doch natürlich retina klar nachdem das
immer noch sehr da kannst du die ganze
dieser tour führung damals bei
mtv und ich wir haben zusammen was
gefunden nämlich und das nennt sich das
wird es finster
und das wird fans das ja auch am anfang
geöffnet da gab es nämlich alle sachen
immer
größer
ja ich mache hier
sowohl natürlich
ich dachte ich muss sehr schnell und
einfach ein ja einfach rein hände sind
gewaschen deshalb ist bei uns immer von
außen nach innen schön arbeiten
vr geht gleich mit beiden rein das ist
immer gut weil jetzt muss ich die
schlüssel halten
wir leben hier die tricks und welche
aufgaben es machen
mehrere kommt mahlt und dann wird es ein
schöner geschmeidiger hefeteig ich halte
er fest es ist als hätte man gott das
ist nicht mehr alle alle gefühle die
hier zu empfinden sind komplett
schwierig ja ja ich weiß es nicht auch
das schlimmste weise was da dran ist
wenn wir das so machen würden im studio
ist okay aber wir gucken gerade 5000
leute die genug deswegen habe ich halt
echt ein bisschen angst weil die sehen
dann noch einfach meine burschen
jüngere schöne hände deine schönen
geschmeidigen handyvertrag wunderschön
ich meine rolle noch ein bisschen mehr
alles nur nicht nur einfach am bäuchlein
okay
ist das okay oder noch mehr
richtig richtig hunger sagst dir ich
auch also
kann man noch dem team was geben sehr
schön
weitermachen oben im shop noch geteilt
da war mehr für später
wir haben es aber gemacht wie sieht es
bei dir die scheiße aussehen sollen aber
ja
noch ein bisschen kneten ich wollte noch
ein bisschen mehr
also muss sagen ich spüre meine gelenke
inzwischen weiß jetzt ein gutes zeichen
ist
dann kneten was hier gleich nochmal
ordentlich durch
da und kann meine hände meine angewiesen
sagt
kanz court gehen
oberarme es ist also
ich muss intelligenter als pamela ich
mache das rennen und dann wird füttern
und ganzen sports ist und dann noch mal
so eine kooperation mit
ich bin auch pamela oliver ja glaub ich
nicht eingeladen und hier
kommst du
mal gucken ein geschenk
die ablöse
wie gut der auslauf wenn das ist nicht
super wird
[Musik]
das ist gut aber ich mache ja auch weil
es dich
da machen wir daraus jetzt eine schöne
künste das ist gerade auf deine hände
gemacht hat dann ist endlich schon
eingeführt falls ja auch mal was nicht
auf eure hände machen wollte sondern ins
gesicht boden wasser als hätten sie hier
ich hab das outfit ganz man immer nach
rose gebrochen ja nicht wirklich komisch
und dann kriegst du den teilnehmern mit
den ball nicht mit den fingern ist nicht
so anstrengend teuer deswegen hast jetzt
die finger starre ja ich habe
gelenkschmerzen
also hier schon immer mit dem handballen
aber ich wollte ihm nicht so viel sagen
weil er dachte schon wissen will dann
haben sie eine kernbohrung seinen
fehlern lerne ja
und noch eine gute nachricht heute ja
ich habe commerce besorgen lassen wir
werden auch weil wird eine friteuse
haben weil dahin frittiert halt schon
nicht so viel weil da habe ich dann
immer alles und
ich hier nicht die ganze zeit sowieso
wir sind draußen und ich finde schon im
fuß sind da müssen auch pommes
frittieren mit ganz viel kommerz gewürz
oder
ok es sich gehört richtig gehört
ich habe es tatsächlich auch schon mal
jemand einfach so mal wieder
zurückgebildet gibt irgendein warmen ort
im input nicht so ne in warendorf ja
also außerdem sind back im backofen ist
ja ganz schön war okay ich sollte jetzt
ein bisschen aufgehen lassen
den denken wir mal auf das passiert was
da kommt was kuscheln mit den teilchen
dann wird das schön war ja
so ne räume hier kurz auf und während
der teig aufgeht machen wir diese diese
champignons vom weihnachtsmarkt gibt
diese richtig lecker das geht ja ja die
bereits fix vor ok ich brauche nur noch
34 minuten bis alle meine mein herrchen
befreit sind
[Musik]
europas
was machst du hier ich mache noch unter
hefeteig dass wir mehr haben zum
verteilen werden die ganze zeit in der
kampfmaschine ja aber ich dachte dieser
maschine stimmen deswegen dachte und
darin aufgehen lassen
[Musik]
ja gut da gibt es jetzt schon begann
fahne aller weihnachtsmarkt richtig
darum brauche mir das wie bettchen
knuffigen
und champignons aliens und später dann
für die sauce béarnaise
olivenöl essig weiß man es nicht machen
sie
schnittlauch schnitte ja wie geht's dir
gut
ist der grill ist schon heiser das heißt
dass frauen frischen schnitt laufen
haben sich eingefunden
in so klein ja wir müssen so wenig kann
man nur kleine portionen fahrer guckst
du
dressing
[Musik]
vierteln ja ich würde vierteln die
werden immer noch ein bisschen kleiner
ja und die zwiebeln
solchen stücken
die schauen sich die stäbchen und ein
bisschen zurecht mit das messer legt
auch ganz ungewohnten dachten ist auch
sehr leicht naja wenn eure messe sind ja
immer so sehr das ist so
aber es ist gut oder schlecht schneidet
gut aber es liegt so
ist die platte an junge die grillplatte
werke zum
ersten mal ja denn es ist hoch erhitzt
das ist wohl jetzt also am besten
bereitet ihr diese pilzpfanne auch in
einer großen pfanne oder bretter für was
ihr hochrechnen könnten keine
beschichtete pfanne muss
sap an ja die platte edelstahl all das
wird funktionieren aber kennst du
ja da gibt es diese riesigen pfannen ich
habe dann auch mal probiert mit einer
ganz riesigen pfanne nehme ich aber
nicht einigen rennen lassen hatte danach
baute von daher erst immer einbrechen
lassen weil sonst blöd
wenn wir da auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
unterwegs letztes jahr haben wir schon
wissen
ja an den ständen die uns nichts mehr zu
essen geben wollten
und dann war so ein stand dann so die
reste zusammengekratzt warum wollten ja
ich bin nichts mehr wie es war so spät
und dann haben die zugemacht und weisen
so halt vier stunden auto gefahren zu
einem dreh mit
wenn schon mal
der ist ja der ist der achter der zu mir
den schlüssel zur stadt
hier kann die rag ausschließen ob das
was überall geschlossen
einfach so
august von einer brücke runter wie bist
du überhaupt ja auch meine abos zu
klauen ich bin mental das problem ist ob
ich nehme das tor auf hoch erhitzen
sie heißt würde keine
sehr heiß ich kontrollieren 80 kannst du
nicht sagen aber es ist auf jeden fall
trat am anfang gemacht zieht er noch mal
ganz gut dann immer was genau ich würde
dann würde wirklich kommt ist ein glas
verdammt ich glaube ich dagegen sprühen
ja bitte da habe ich eine rechte seite
ist aus damit wir ein bisschen
regulieren können
ich mache mache ich kann dir auch mal
voll machen da kommt zumindest ein
bisschen mehr hoch
dann probiert schon mal das wir sonst
habe ich kein platz mehr kannst du schon
mal verraten auch schon mal gucken wir
mal
was du hier den dezibel beträgt 1000
tests noch nicht
[Musik]
also dann habe ich die da hinten drauf
ja mach das gerne meine augen drehen
[Musik]
ich habe mich so super in bünde ds
intensiven aber ja ich habe so mega
empfindlichen augen das hört nicht auf
wenn es ganz schlimm war vorher sollten
ja aber ich einmal diese öle orten aus
rhede hat den augen weil bei uns ist und
weil das ich so freut
es mich gut ich hasse zwiebeln aber so
lecker
noch die
ich habe jetzt hier noch den knoblauch
jetzt in reibe ich mir schon kleine uns
zu ende und die creme fraiche
dass du da so ohne emotionen durchkommt
das ist wirklich ich habe auch keine
kritiker gehört
was los ist mein erzfeind also in der
luft im magen ist gut
[Musik]
creme fraiche knoblauch waren heute
einfach so allem wegen vorbei dies in
der stadt mannheim gibt dem knoblauch
damals olivenöl dran
ich glaube ich noch eine taucherbrille
von sturm extrem mit der triebe
mein asse
könnte auch selber machen da geht es
doch auf einem kanal rezepte haben jetzt
gesagt kommt wir sind es den vorschlag
dass man mich selber
hässlich und arm an sie
und dann noch salz pfeffer schnittlauch
vor wenn das wichtigste vergessen eine
löffel ablage wie kann ich hier ohne
löffel ablage aber wir waren auch nicht
haben wir zusammen geschrieben ist schon
eine weile her weil ja ich habe einen
löffel über auflagen die mode
das habe ich mir gestern los ist ja dann
könne die leute lieben hassen
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen ist ja oben
sitzt ein bisschen merkwürdig auch dass
man sieht das immer wenn du dann so
sauer reimer na klar die sagen überlegt
ob die löffel
die vom elternhaus in mannheim
wir kochen wie seit wochen alle sind
glücklich mein auge treten nicht mehr es
wird immer besser sein auge wird besser
schwillt ab
so salz pfeffer hatten wir euch hier ist
lecker lecker
somit
ich rief nun immer ob da weiß auch wer
vertreten ist mit den mag ich gar nicht
aber er ist nicht drin
du hast mir sehr gut
[Applaus]
ich habe inspector spürnasen das stimmt
tatsächlich
wollte es eigentlich mal den support vor
den spielen würde dann wärst du
inspektor spüren
[Musik]
business schnittlauch ich hoffe dass
schmecken halt auch
bestimmt
wir fragen dann ein paar mutige ob sie
probieren wollen einmal mit einmal ohne
jetzt wird's will jetzt richtig würde
der wagen wir haben halt nur so ein
abhaken platz zum handlanger des weges
bisschen schwierig aber wir kriegen das
stimmt und wir haben noch mehr spachtel
jo weil die bräuchte ich jetzt gerne us
sowie der ice maker dieser einstellung
wir leider nichts mit den höchst noch
mal was machen
er ist amtlich oder nächsten deutsch ja
der mit dem größten im ice cream youtube
kanal ist deutschland hatte schon kennen
wir haben ein ganz cooler typ
[Musik]
ok jetzt noch schön hörst du nicht
schaffen
ich würde aber sagen so die pflanze die
machen wir nicht hier auf dem grill
sondern die manchmal draußen im gefäß
bisschen bio paprika
nur ein mal rüber
[Musik]
heute leben hier schon mal eine zange
bereiten verliehen
ein bisschen mehr zu kontern
wir waren nach der 10
eine zange zustande
dass da keine großen themen aber
ich bin ganz schlecht mit mir hier
ist wirklich
wir machen jetzt ein bisschen kleinere
gärten teilen kann jeder ausprobieren
und die kann man auch süß belegen mit
dem teller sind sogar jetzt schon mit
teller gesehen
lukas krämer
ich habe bloß die leute auch wenn die
richtigen tipps holen so wodurch die den
gleichschritt auf das uns gleich zum
thema am besten aus legen dann kann das
bisschen abtropfen lassen oder nehmen
uns die teller zum ausgeben
[Musik]
ich kann mir machen immer zwei immer
zwei zweite fritteuse ist leider nicht
es ist nur romantisch ja man kann uns ja
auch buchen für dates also falls ihr
heiraten wollte und eine antrag machen
wollte
vorbei kriegt zwei paar passende die
friedhöfe antrag
festival events aber ich muss sagen wir
bräuchten größeren puffer wenn man so
alle kosten wollen ich hab dir ich habe
mir gesagt wenn ben saly und das könnte
meine kommentare schreiben und die auf
dem fuß braucht weil ich sage ich ja mag
zwar gleich zum 40 tonner
lkw katrin bohle und dann schon wieder
die küche der einbauen dann im job zu
hause und dem lkw brannte ein wagen also
ob das nicht gehen würde du kannst du
sogar noch ausgaben und das sogar im
backstage dann kannst du mal keinen plan
was machen ja komm ich war schon mal
kurz meine hände dass ich sie entfetten
kann und dann können wir gleich schon
mal welche rausgeben
also ans team ja
[Musik]
dieser gibt es ja keine weihnachtsmärkte
wahrscheinlich wieder deswegen aber
gedacht bauen wir hier am standort wir
machen weihnachten jetzt schon immer auf
jeden fall mal wintermarkt natürlich
höchst offiziell spricht schon gut und
du passt auch die anderen das hat ihr
euch im auge ja und liegt auch immer
wieder neue
nachbarn
machen wir
sport ob ich ein paar zweck league für
veganer wobei der rest ist auch nicht
vegan also auch ein
einfach einfach rein
ja
guck mal ganz schön verrückt ich mach
dir das hier auch schon mal kurz die
anderen geräte hier markt nochmal hier
schon wieder kind und ich würde sagen
'du wirst der vorkoster
immer immer etwas zurückgeben so kämen
falls ihr noch
etwas schneller
und dann hat sich die lage nach dem
hammerlos die kann man herzhaft und süß
jedes mal wenn verlassen hat mache und
dippel das sei ganz frischen die sind
schon ein bisschen kühler ja dann diesen
scheiß bürgerrechte zu machen und dann
habe ich dir daneben sollte schaffen
zum probieren
macht mal dass ich mit der hand ja ich
dachte nur die
überhaupt der mann ist multitaskingfähig
das denn
ich mache einfach schnell noch ein paar
also haben wir sie dann läuft's weiter
damit hier alle hat das ganze team
glücklich wird wir haben auch noch die
shop mitarbeiter und untersuchen würde
alles gemacht
st
einmal für dich
mach ich muss das essen ich hätte
natürlich ganz anders
das sieht sehr gut aus du hast das jetzt
gemischt mit
ok also nicht zum tippen sondern damit
auch schon fertig dass wir mal und dann
automatisch
okay das guthaben oder essig
und ich finde gerade immer so winter
weihnachten dann ist schon immer schon
das herz des verbandes
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt wird gerade in den
spannungsbogen franken ich mach das und
da war und dann darfst du noch ein süßes
topping aus
[Musik]
snogard aus von fieber
deutsches produkt
das man dafür
[Musik]
dass toni lang steht
dann vielleicht als andere namen
richtig würzig und
ich komme gleich raus
meine freundin ist
das schon so lange nicht gesehen hallo
freunde
und
mit frittiertem essen machen wir glauben
aber fast jedem glück oder so ein
david ja
kommt einfach unser zauberer fahrrad
natürlich leute
voll gut ich würde sagen wir frittieren
jetzt hier weiter machen hier haben nur
ich muss sagen ich finde die kombi
fahren muss auch voll weil ich habe mal
aus versehen ich habe mal eine herzhafte
kriegen gemacht so eine süße die hat
sagt damit knoblauch und dann hab ich
die mit pflaumenmus und das war echter
hammer also wir müssen jetzt hier kurz
weitermachen nicht schwimmen wir müssen
hier produzieren
die sind jetzt richtig gut siehst du die
diese jetzt perfekt jetzt ist genau
perfekt heißt die kammer zeigen
[Musik]
bitteschön torgau ist nur für euch nur
fürs team
und dadurch kannst
[Musik]
wir sind die beiden hände
kommen wir packen hier führt dabei und
mir gern noch vertrauen dass jemand
ihren teller nein ich hab ich wollte das
nicht
sehr lecker
zweimal
schön gibt es hier
knoblauch ist einfach lecker das stimmt
machst du so lange mache drauf auch noch
beiden riesen zu kommunizieren das kann
man zusammen aber ihr könnt mich doch
jetzt probiert mal
hört man die 2
laut werden
[Musik]
der perfekt da würde seine mission
erfüllt ist glücklich team ist glücklich
sind glücklich machen wir jetzt nur
glücklich mit den resten die wir
natürlich noch haben und ganz wichtig
ich muss noch eine woche mitnehmen ja ja
das kommt jetzt mache ich jetzt gleich
so ich habe eine richtung
taucha dafür ein anhänger
ist groß das gleiche konzept natürlich
wie immer auch solisten das klappte er
macht gott
[Musik]
hat das schöne guten tag ich habe es nie
zu einer magic pause gezogen und habe
hier untersuchen
bitte liebe grafikabteilung nicht nicht
animieren nicht animieren
okay wir sind die folge ich habe den
wunderbaren alexander straub hier hallo
hallo guten tag
ich bin
und ich habe eine angel mikrofon wir
kein problem ich wollte mal helfen zu
können danke schön so etwas auf wir
machen den sommerpause natürlich auch
redlich verdient ich wurde schon
und ich habe mitgemacht und vorne alle
unterschiedlich ganz wichtig und in
halle gleich
meine karte ausziehen ja ich bin
eh du darfst jetzt auch mal was glaubst
du bist teil der magie
ja
schaut sich dann merkte ich dreh mich
auch weg
die gehalte leute hier
okay sagt mannschaften praktika zurück
und nicht vergessen ja ganz wichtig dass
auch ingolstadt
auch gute nicht mehr vergessen ganz
wichtig sondern die karten um zurück
gestern richtig karten wieder zu finden
und zwar einer nacht anfang an mit
deiner kamen ganz spektakulär
hier ganz aus der mitte heraus springt
eine karte das ist die pick up
also die begeisterung die ist ihm ins
gesicht bestätigen diese emotionsloser
mensch das ist aber vollkommen richtig
ok ok gemacht haben wir schon mal und
jetzt die daten auch wieder spektakulär
es war deine karte
märz 4
geschlagen
[Musik]
in der digital divide
mir nicht an zu weinen das ist prinzip
ich glaub ich zum brief aus hogwarts und
danke für die zauber pause sehr geehrter
gibt's noch einstellen
das war doch mal von meiner mutter die
schon sehr alt einer der ersten nummer
immer noch mal ganz schnell hier ganz
schnell und zwar wollte die neue karte
ja kommen wir noch mal los angeles sally
soll eine neue karte raus uns die ist
perfekt sagt es nochmal ein
mal statt und dieses mal gerade zurück
dieses mal es ist ganz wichtig dass ich
nicht fertig gerade gar nicht
das bedeutet also dass wichtiger ist ich
möchte gerade nochmal einmal forums
durch nicht dass du sie gemerkt dass
mode zurückgesteckt das klar machen
immer die meisten zuschauer das heißt du
weißt die karte ist aber nicht oben und
die karte nicht versehentlich unten
gelandet sondern sie müsste irgendwo
noch in der mitte sie weiter und weiter
und lässt das wissen wir nicht genau und
ich werde jetzt hier gleich jede
einzelne karte zeigen und du merkst dir
einfach die position an der deine karte
ist
jetzt ist sagt scheller trägt zwar die
kurzversion bisschen bereits in dem
bereich wo warst du delikate gemerkt
wir mal was anders dann nutzen jetzt
einfach vielleicht eine weibliche
intuition und seine oder dem ist die von
freddy ganze heraussuchen und wenn ich
hier drückt man durchgehen
ich höre jetzt hier durchgeht und du
hast du für deine karte könnte jetzt
kommt stocker
das war jetzt ein bisschen zögerlich du
musst schon bisher wenig isst du muss
davon überzeugt sein wenn es wieder so
einiges aus und die kaufen es ist der
wahnsinn sie macht sich wichtig es nicht
glauben dass er verraten wird weil dann
der getötete von anderen wagen korrekt
kodex so in diesem sinne wie gesagt ich
mag dahinter klingel aufgestellt also
immer wenn es da ein bisschen langsamer
wird einfach mal drauf kriegen dann
kommt das habe finde ich nicht
dankeschön für diese tolle zauber pause
wir bedanken uns bei alex weitere
zaubertricks gibt's dann in freddys
video
schnipsel zum laufen will ihr könnt ihr
entweder den mittelteil wegschneiden
oder einfach drin lassen bisher gehalten
wow
kannst du mich schnipsen auf hawaii
viel spaß beim kind
ich kann auch durch die zeigen
kannst du machen dass der logistik
entwickelt ich möchte nicht
möchte nicht damit auch zaubern
ich will einfach mal mama okay ich gehe
zu sehen und wenn ich schnitze dann ist
es der
ich habe hier überall
wollen sie noch mehr
sein fazit karten kann das ist jetzt
habe ich hier meine hallo es wird aber
ist die pause lange vorbei wird die sich
in ihren spielen jetzt
nein
ich weiß nicht wie es geht kommt das
backen